der bundestag debattiert der seite
morgen um 9 uhr in der generaldebatte
über die politik der bundesregierung der
nächste riesen hier im plenarsaal ist
der ehrenvorsitzende der afg ehemaliger
fraktionschefs und parteichef und 81
jahren ist alexander gauland
mittlerweile alt
meine damen und herren
selten noch ist eine ins neue sub
gekommene regierung so schnell und so
gründlich auf dem boden der tatsachen
angekommen
wenn es nicht um deutschland um uns alle
ginge könnte man fast schadenfreude
finden aber das ist hier nicht mein ziel
da bittet ein grüner wirtschaftsminister
dessen ziel das ende der fossilen
energiewirtschaft ist arabische scheichs
um flüssiggas
und eine außenministerin die von
feministischer außenpolitik träumt muss
sich eine neue sicherheitsarchitektur
ausdenken und allem steht ein
regierungschef vor dessen partei noch
kürzlich
bewaffnete drohnen für unvereinbar mit
den deutschen friedens wird wir haben
eine damen und herren in puncto
sicherheit hat die regierung schnell
gelernt
und 100 milliarden für die bundeswehr
sind schon ein erstaunlicher lernerfolg
für politiker die im festen glauben an
eine regelbasierte
multilaterale außenpolitik groß geworden
sind
doch meine damen und herren wie immer in
fällen schon überkompensation
droht jetzt die übertragung
ich weiß es schwer im angesicht von
ruinen
einem angriffskrieg und millionen
flüchtlinge die eigenen fehler also die
fehler des westens in der vergangenheit
zu benennen nur so viel
man soll niemals einer großmacht eine
großmacht demütigen
bismarker dahin 1870 71 gehört die
sieger des ersten weltkrieges ins
1919 in wasser
und der westen weile damen und herren
leider nach
1989 denn was wir getan haben war eine
demütigung russlands wir haben eine
weltordnung versucht aufzubauen ohne auf
diese großmacht rücksicht zu nehmen und
das meine damen und herren heißt
dass trotz allem was geschehen ist
dort dieses angriffskrieges eine
europäische friedensordnung nur mit
russland aber niemals gegen das größte
land europas möglich ist
es ist der irrtum des russischen
präsidenten zu glauben
größe käme allein aus den gewehrläufen
oder heute aus der atomraketen
größe und stärke eines landes beruhen zu
meisten auf der akzeptanz des staates
nach innen wie nach außen
und das ist das defizit des russischen
präsidenten
die großen zahlen auf die er sich gerne
beruft waren reformer
alexander der erste
der bezwinger napoleons und alexander
der zweite der bauernbefreiung
was sollten was können wir tun um
russland auf diesen europäischen weg
zurückzuführen
meine damen und herren wir können
eintreten als ehrlicher makler
für eine neutrale keime das wäre die
zukunft
meine damen und herren damit ich nicht
verstanden werde
neutralität heißt nicht
neutralität der gedanken und herzen
aber neutralität der tagen
sanktionen die das russische volk
treffen sind falsch wie die lieferung
von angriffswaffen die nichts besser
aber vieles noch schlimmer machen oder
gar kriegshandlung wie die sperrung des
luftraums über der ukraine
und ich bin dem bundeskanzleramt war
dass er ganz klar gesagt hat dass wir
nicht teil dieses krieges dieser
auseinandersetzung sind und dass das
auch so bleiben muss
meine damen und herren
neutralität im angesicht eines dritten
weltkrieges mit atomwaffen
ist eben nicht mit unterlassener
hilfeleistung eines privatmanns zu
vergleichen weil das opfer nicht
mitglied der freiwilligen feuerwehr ist
wie henrik bruder kürzlich in der welt
meinte
und nein die werte zwar herausgeber der
welt wir versagen nicht vor der
geschichte als deutsche wenn wir auf
dieser neutralität
und auf dem frieden beharren
und meine damen und herren ich
weiß es viel kritik geübt worden wie wir
uns nach der rede des ukrainischen
präsidenten verhalten haben das will ich
nicht wieder aufrufen doch auch der
ukrainische präsident kann nicht wollen
die freiheit der ukraine auf den
trümmern europas zu errichten
im atomzeitalter ist der kompromiss kein
happy end
sondern
überlebensnotwendig das wusste gerade
egon bahr wärme zu rechnen
am ende wird eine neutrale und
demilitarisierte ukraine von allen
beteiligten das bekenntnis ab fordern ob
tod und zerstörung wirklich notwendig
waren dieses ergebnis zu erzielen und
die bundesregierung die workshops für
daran gemessen werden wie nachdrücklich
sie sich für eine solche lösung verwandt
hat es ist das eine nach dem völkerrecht
ein theoretisches recht auf bunten ist
bündniszugehörigkeit zu haben und das
andere in einer staaten ordnung wie sie
nun einmal ist seinen platz mit klugheit
zu behaupten
einflusssphäre verschwinden nicht
dadurch dass man sie leugnet und ein
abbruch aller beziehungen zu russland
ändert nichts an seiner lage größe
unserem geopolitischen einfluss
pragmatisches handeln bleibt deshalb
auch hier oberstes gebot ich bedanke
mich
soweit die sicht von alexander gauland
hf die gibt es eine rechtfertigung für
diesen krieg muss man sich da fragen der
nächste redner hier in der
generaldebatte im deutschen bundestag
das ist die kulturstaatsministerin
claudia roth
denn auch der bereich kultur sowie
ostdeutschland und integration gehört
der in dem haus sechs titel des
bundeskanzlers der ihr eigentlich
kolleginnen und kollegen krieg hass in
europa menschen werden getötet werden
verletzt menschen müssen fliehen
familien werden zerrissen existenzen
zerstört dahinter tritt alles zurück
wirkt alles andere klein und unbedeutend
doch gerade jetzt in dieser situation
müssen wir uns auf das besinnen was wir
mit unseren mitteln tun können um zu
helfen wo wir helfen können und gerade
jetzt gerade jetzt geht es darum unser
demokratisches modell unsere so
wertvolle kultur der demokratie zu
stärken und zu verteidigen
und deswegen ist kulturpolitik auch
sicherheitspolitik
dieser krieg zerstört nicht nur das
leben von millionen von menschen er
zerstört auch ukrainische kulturgüter er
macht ukrainische künstlerinnen und
künstler journalisten und
journalistinnen sie sich mit großem
einsatz für eine demokratische
entwicklung in der ukraine stark gemacht
haben zu verfolgten und zu vertriebenen
bedroht sind aber auch viele russische
künstlerinnen journalisten und
wissenschaftlerinnen die für die letzten
freiräume gekämpft haben und nun auf der
flucht vor dem putin regime sind
deswegen sage ich wenn wir es ernst
meinen mit den werten die für alle
menschen gelten wenn wir die freiheit
der meinung der kunst der kultur
verteidigen wollen dann unterstützen wir
jetzt alle diejenigen die für diese
werte eintreten
[Applaus]
gegen eine nationalistische
instrumentalisierung von kultur dann
wieder stehen wir versuchen von kultur
boykotten und öffnen unser land für die
die heute auf der flucht vor kriegen
treibern für autokraten und
verbrecherischen regime sind
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
werden wir nur gemeinsam schaffen
ressort übergreifend in zusammenarbeit
mit bund und ländern
[Musik]
zwischen innen und außen und nicht
zuletzt zwischen regierung und parlament
kultur und medienpolitik sollten wir
heute mehr denn je gemeinsam angehen ich
dachte ich an dieser stelle ganz
besonders bei annalena baerbock aber
auch bei allen landes ministerinnen und
ministern und kultureinrichtungen für
diese zusammenarbeit bedanken wir haben
in einem ersten schritt in meinem haus
eine schnittstelle eingerichtet eine
task force die innen und außen
zivilgesellschaft und länder verbindet
gemeinsam organisieren der hilfe und
aufnahmeprogramme für künstler innen für
journalisten wir unterstützen
aufnahmebereite kultureinrichtungen und
wir koordinieren ad hoc maßnahmen zur
rettung von kulturgütern ein thema liegt
mir dabei ganz besonders am herzen und
deswegen haben wir als bundesregierung
ist auch auf die agenda der g 7 gesetzt
wir müssen das demokratische
gesellschaftsmodell verteidigen und
stärken und das heißt uns um die
meinungsfreiheit und die
meinungsvielfalt kümmern um unabhängige
medien die seriös und die verlässlich
informieren bei uns aber auch in europa
und im globalen rahmen und st besonders
im blick auf den angriffskrieg gegen die
ukraine gemeinsam mit dem auswärtigen
amt der schöpflin und der aus stein
stiftung mit reporter ohne grenzen und
anderen zivilgesellschaftlichen
organisationen wollen wir arbeit und
aufnahmemöglichkeiten für bedrohte
journalistinnen und journalisten
schaffen liebe demokratinnen und
demokraten
ich bin überzeugt kultur lebt im
öffentlichen raum und der öffentliche
raum lebt von ihrer kultur ist ein
lebenselixier für unsere demokratie und
deswegen ist kulturpolitik auch
gesellschaftspolitik und die müssen wir
gerade in und nach der pandemie stärken
wir müssen gerade jetzt dafür sorgen
dass sie ihre kräfte entfalten kann und
was für kräfte sie entfalten kann und
wie stark ihre stimme ist das haben wir
doch erst am letzten sonntag gesehen
beim sound of peace hier in berlin am
brandenburger tor doch diese kraft sie
funktioniert nicht indem wir nur
fördermittel ausreichen und einzelne
herausgehobene institutionen bedenken
wir wollen die kultur als einen offenen
raum begreifen indem wir ideen projekte
visionen fördern und unterstützen und
indem wir es ermöglichen dass menschen
angst frei ihre stimme erheben können
diese freiheit von kunst und kultur ihre
widerständigkeit und verschiedenheit
genau das genau das brauchen wir wie die
luft zum atmen und deshalb habe ich
gesagt dass ich die
kulturstaatsministerin der demokratie
sein möchte weil ich für die
kulturpolitik einer offenen gesellschaft
steht sage ich eine offene gesellschaft
unterschiedlichster auch
widerstreitender ideen und
ausdrucksformen gedeiht nur wenn sie
gegensätze aushalten leidenschaften
ertragen und freiheit gewähren kann und
dafür brauchen wir mittel und deshalb
bin ich sehr froh dass das
bundeskabinett den zweiten
regierungsentwurf für den haushalt 20 22
beschlossen und den etat für kultur und
medien auf insgesamt 2,14 milliarden
euro erhöht hat das ist eine steigerung
von zehn prozent gegenüber dem vorjahr
und ich bin zufrieden dass wir mit
diesem haushaltsentwurf
impulse setzen können die wirklich in
unserem sinne wirken werden und auch
dafür möchte ich für diesen entwurf
werden diese mittel sind gut angelegt
für die kreativität unserer gesellschaft
indem wir gemeinsam mit robert habeck
ministerium das thema kreativwirtschaft
stärken und ressort übergreifend
gemeinsam fördern worden für die
vielfalt und demokratie in unserer
gesellschaft indem wir zusätzliche
mittel gegen rechtsextremismus und
rassismus bereitstellen indem wir uns
der aufarbeitung des kolonialismus
energisch widmen und neue mittel vor
allem für die gemeinsame kulturelle
zukunft mit afrika und den ländern des
globalen südens zur verfügung stellen
wollen und vor allem indem wir
nachhaltigkeit und klimapolitik zu einem
zentralen thema machen mit dem sektor
vorhaben green shooting für die
filmwirtschaft haben wir begonnen und
nun verankern wir mit einer eigenen
arbeitseinheit kultur und nachhaltigkeit
der da lachen sie dann informieren sie
sich was das bedeutet alle produzenten
filmemacher öffentliche private sind
dabei wenn sie beitragen wollen gegen
die klimakrise auch in der kulturbranche
und wir werden jetzt in einer eigenen
ausgereicht kultur und nachhaltigkeit
über alle sektoren hinaus verstärken und
am aufbau des green culture deck
arbeiten des arbeiten den der im
koalitionsvertrag vereinbart haben
freiheit vielfalt und nachhaltigkeit das
sind die themen die uns den weg nach
vorn in die zukunft weisen sollen die
werden sie gemeinsam anpacken und die
kulturpolitik für eine koalition des
aufbruchs gestalten und all das will ich
in einem plenum der kultur in enger
zusammenarbeit in abstimmung mit allen
erreichen die in der kultur und die für
die kultur wirken künstlerinnen und
künstler kultureinrichtung bund länder
kommunen und zivilgesellschaft ich will
gemeinsam mit ihnen die kräfte von kunst
und kultur weiter entfesseln und ich
freue mich liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wenn ich sie in großer mehrheit
an meiner seite weist vielen dank
die küche staatsministerin claudia roth
auch etc tier zu diesem posten
die nächste
debatte ist nicht autos
und hier noch mal eine ermahnung mund
nasen bedeckung zu tragen also otto
fricke von der fdp seit 2002 sitzt mit
einer unterbrechung von vier jahren hier
im deutschen fernsehen mal vorsitzende
des haushaltsausschusses aber er hätte
auch viele andere jobs annehmen können
in der die fdp erwarte
haushaltspolitischer sprecher bleiben
das ist er nun aber kann ich dann noch
wieder als nicht danach haushälter mit
der analyse der situation anfang aber
das ist glaube ich auch eine gute
aufgabenteilung innerhalb dieser
koalition meine damen und herren ich
will zum nachdenken anregen in dieser
zeit was ist eigentlich unsere aufgabe
was ist die aufgabe von uns allen nicht
nur von der koalition sondern von uns
allen als parlamentarier in zeiten eines
krieges in europa in zeiten der not es
ist vor allen dingen eine aufgabe von
der wir wissen dass das was wir heute
besprechen am ende des jahres sich noch
mal ganz anders darstellen wird und der
haushalt den wir beraten am ende des
jahres noch einmal ganz anders sein wird
weil eben damals diese zeitenwende da
ist und wir noch gar nicht alle genau
wissen wie sie sich auswirken wird aber
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass ein
haushalt dafür vorsorge trifft wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass wir nicht
buchhalterisch rangehen sondern dass wir
dafür sorgen wo die grundlinien geht und
deswegen will ich das noch mal deutlich
sagen im kernhaushalt zeigen wir an wo
wir hin wollen wie wir zur einhaltung
der schuldenbremse kommen wollen aber
durch den ergänzungs haushalt zeigen wir
auch dass wir die realitäten annehmen
die realität eines krieges die realität
in der not die realitäten der flucht der
ergänzungs haushalt auch das möchte ich
noch mal gerne den kollegen von cdu csu
sagen der wird in diesem haushalt dann
integriert der wird nicht am ende
alleine stehen sondern lassen sich das
gerne von kollegen hause mal erklären
der wird dann zusammengeführt und das
ist auch nicht wie sie behauptet haben
irgendetwas neues der kollege dobrindt
weiß dass inzwischen hat aus münchen auf
den bösen an aufgeregt wie ich gehört
habe franz josef strauß hat mit
ergänzungs haushalten in den 60er jahren
gearbeitet als die notwendigkeit dafür
bestand wir nehmen also ein mittel der
vorausschau wissen wie die lage ist
wissen dass wir darauf aufbauen müssen
das ist haushaltspolitik wie sie auch
sein muss meine damen und herren
damen und herren ich will doch
sozietäten noch zwei drei worte sagen
und zwar zum thema verteidigung ist
schon viel um die frage sagte der
minister aber herr kollege merz wenn sie
sagen die cdu hat immer gewollt ich zeig
dir mal was der unterschied schon in der
realen politik erst der entwurf
einzelplan 14 verteidigung für dieses
jahr 50 milliarden ja wir auf 50 mann
für die nächsten drei jahre bauen sie
jeweils 47 milliarden ab was macht diese
koalition wissen wie schwierig das für
manchen kollegen wir bauen auf alleine
da in der planung sind wir schon besser
als sie es unter einer cdu geführten
regierung mit einem cdu in einer celik
umverteilungs ministerin war das ist der
unterschied zwischen glaube und realität
ich würde kulturell immer sagen das ist
der unterschied zwischen dichtung und
wahrheit meine damen und herren dann
komme ich nochmal zu der frage und das
dann zum schluss zur verfassungsänderung
ich fand das schon bemerkenswert herr
merz dass sie ihre fraktion jetzt gesagt
haben dass sie nur so viel stimmen geben
würden dass du für 2000 reicht dann sage
ich den kollegen von cdu csu dann könnt
ihr schon mal gucken wer nachher
zustimmen darf bei einer
verfassungsänderung der nicht und wäre
dann erklärt oh ja ich war zwar ab und
zwar frei gewählt aber so wie ich durfte
nur so abstimmen wie meine fraktion das
sagte das ist kein umgang mit
verfassungsänderung und dann nehmen sie
sich ein beispiel an der fdp in den
letzten jahren es war nicht nur bei der
digitalisierung so es war auch sollte es
gegen gemeinden bei der frage ist
schlecht gegen wie es wie es mit der
gewerbesteuer ging wer hat da nicht
verfassungsänderung mitgemacht und die
zweidrittelmehrheit ihn trinkt die fdp
in der opposition dies nicht müsste aber
aus verantwortung getan hat meine damen
und herren von der cdu da sie da sie
wissen dass ich immer gerne mit sechs
beendet durch das auch dieses mal ich
weiß jetzt schon sonst wieder ärger
bewertet die haare bekommen sie mit
roter berg so einfach schwer wer zu spät
bereut könig lear erster akt erste szene
und ich hoffe sie haben besser zehn
danke
otto fricke in voller fahrt beruft sich
hier auf französisch der aus der auch
ergänzungs haushalte hatte und diese
ergänzungs haushalt zeige dass wir die
realitäten annehmen es sei ein mittel
der vorausscheidung sich
der fraktionsvorsitzende der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion als das wort
[Applaus]
mit meiner rede möchte ich mich mal bei
ihnen und auch bei der kollegin hat
bedanken dass sie sich so wacker alleine
schlagen auf dem präsidium diese woche
das ist ja auch nicht selbstverständlich
dass sie es zu zweit hier die ganze
woche schon locken also vielen
herzlichen dank aber das wars jetzt
ehrlich gesagt auch mit den
freundlichkeiten weil wir wirklich
genauso wie es mein
fraktionsvorsitzender vorhin gesagt hat
ich auch betonen wollte dass wir den
bundeskanzler sehr dankbar war dass er
in seiner regierungserklärung vor drei
wochen von einer zeitenwende gesprochen
hat das ganze beschrieben hat und dass
er ehrlich ausgeführt hat was das jetzt
einfach braucht und deswegen gebe ich zu
habe ich mir auch sehr viel erwartet
weil es ja auch nach der
regierungserklärung ihre erste rede
wieder war bundeskanzler nach dieser
sonntagsrede
dass sie heute noch mal was großes
ganzes aufzeigen und was war das grüne
rede ich sage ihnen ganz offen bei mir
hängen geblieben viel lob viel eigenlob
kam früher gelernt eigenlob stinkt und
man hat ja auch der regierungsbank
tatsächlich sich gar nicht schnell genug
weg decken können wie man von ihnen in
grund und boden gelobt wurde da war ein
lob an nancy faeser da war ein lob an
christian lindner da war ein lob an anna
lena werbung da war ein lob an robert
habeck man habe ich darauf gewartet wann
lobte denn endlich mal die
bundesfamilienministerin
und dann ist die einzige die nicht
gelobt wurde
das halte kann ich geguckt stimmt jetzt
wo es wurde auch nicht gelobt habe bei
den spiegel auch nicht und warum wurde
eine spiegel nicht gelobt weil natürlich
auch überhaupt keine familien politik in
diesem land stattfindet liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
aber es gibt sicher dass die mannen der
familienpolitik ist ja nicht erst eine
erfindung jetzt der grünen sondern die
mangelnde familienpolitik weil ihr heute
soviel vergangenheitsbewältigung vor den
ampelkoalition im stattgefunden hat die
mangelnde familienpolitik war schon in
der letzten legislaturperiode
da hat olaf scholz damals als
vizekanzler auch nicht als frau den
abflug gemacht hat um wahlkampf in
berlin zu machen es für notwendig
erkannt das familienministerium
nachzubesetzen und frau lamprecht eine
zusatzaufgabe bekommen die sie auch
nicht genau wie die aktuell also auch da
ein roter faden zieht sich durch diese
rote bundesregierung durch das muss man
tatsächlich machen und ich meine wenn es
nicht so traurig wäre können was sagen
na gut so ist aldi amt hier in der
regierung aber ich sage ihnen ganz offen
das herz schmerzt wenn man sieht dass
familie frauen kinder auf der
prioritätenliste dieser regierung ganz
ganz ganz unten angesiedelt sind und
das ist wirklich sehr traurig weil im
moment uns das schicksal der geflüchtete
frau und kinder extrem berührt sie ein
paar jungs ein schutz verdient sie
fliehen vor putins banken und deswegen
sind sie bei uns willkommen und wir
stehen und das haben sie einfach noch
nicht auf dem schirm nicht kurzfristig
irgendetwas zu tun wir stehen vor einer
jahrhundertaufgabe wir haben jetzt schon
mehr als
225.000 frauen und kinder genauso weiß
was nicht das hat der kanzler heute auch
gesagt sie tag heute und seiner rede wir
wissen nicht wie viele flüchtlinge
kommen ok eine steile these führen
amtierenden bundeskanzler aber wir
könnten es wissen wie viele tatsächlich
da sind wir wissen es nicht warum weil
unser land nicht systematisch
registriert weil die verteilung nicht
koordiniert wird weil die teilhabe nicht
organisiert wird das heißt die
bundesregierung hat sich noch nicht
darauf vorbereitet die aufnahme der
menschen zu koordinieren die den schutz
vor den bomben suchen das ist wirklich
skandalös liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
von der handel
herr scholz ich erwarte dass sie das
jetzt mal zur chefsache machen wenn du
schon so ein trauerspiel ist mit ihren
ministerien teilweise dass sie noch
nicht mal das lob verdient haben haben
auch nicht alle diese leute gelobt haben
aber wenn das schon nicht der fall ist
dann müssen sie es einfach zur chefsache
machen dann schauen sie doch mal bitte
nach polen da reicht ein blick zu
unseren nachbarn da kommen auf jeden tag
viele flüchtlinge an und alle die
ankommen werden dort auch registriert
spannender weise mit einer deutschen
software wie könnten wir im eigenen land
auch nutzen und deswegen ist es ein
offenbarungseid zu sagen wir wissen das
nicht sondern es ist eine software die
in deutschland entwickelt wurde die in
polen genutzt wird wir brauchen die
registrierungspflicht und wir brauchen
keine bundesregierung die hier in der
verantwortung luft hat
und nicht nur sie wissen es nicht sie
können sich ja noch nicht mal bei den
fachministerin erkundigen nancy faeser
hat gesagt glaskugel irgendwie mit
glaskugel wie gesagt die
familienministerin weit über 100 tage
abgetaucht und die
verteidigungsministerin blamiert
deutschland in brüssel das heißt ich
würde mir wünschen dass sie einladen
aufwecken das sie dann wirklich mal
sagen frauen und kinder jetzt mal zuerst
und das koordiniert aus dem kanzleramt
raus das wird auf jeden fall
funktionieren weil erst wenn wir jede
frau wenn wir jedes kind registrieren
können wir sie schützen dann wissen wir
gibt es verwandtschaft dann wissen wir
gibt es unterkünfte dann können bund
länder und kommunen plane ich habe dann
in der letzten woche an der gleichen
stelle schon mal gesagt unsere
kommunalpolitiker von kommunal politiker
erwarten sich mehr von dieser
bundesregierung die meisten vor ort
wirklich hilfe notwendig ist die
organisierten matratzen und decken sie
organisiert eingewöhnung in
kindertagesstätten in unseren schulen
trainiert schon länger damit dass die
kinder hier bleiben bei uns aber unser
kanzler sagt wir wissen einfach nicht
wie viele das sind das ist ein
kontrollverlust den wir hier haben und
ja wir haben momentan das ist ja auch
von allen erwähnt worden eine große
welle der solidarität aber sie kann auch
schnell vorbei sein wenn die
ehrenamtlichen einfachen merken das
nicht völlig allein auf weiter flur sind
eher harmlos auch koordiniert werden das
wollen unsere hilfsteams übrigens auf
denen ich auch danke an dieser stelle
und was mich wirklich immer extrem zur
weißglut bringt es wenn sie sagen wir
tun alles was notwendig ist oder wenn
väter sagt wenn jetzt dann taten
stattfinden wenn skrupellose kriminelle
versuchen die hilflose situation
auszunutzen
dann sagt sie wir reagieren mit aller
härte des gesetzes
man sage ich ihnen dass es auch zu wenig
im nachgang zu reagieren bänden schon
mal was passiert ist es reicht doch
nicht mehr frau die vergewaltigt wurde
zu sagen im namen schützen mir dann
diejenige oder wir kümmern uns um die es
muss vorher verhindert werden dass es
gar nicht zu solchen straftaten
deswegen brauchen wir jetzt einen
umfassenden schutzschirm für die frau
und die kinder aus der ukraine
wir brauchen die registrierung für alle
abgründe und ich wiederhole noch mal
meine frage aus der letzten woche auch
ans bfs de france
bundesfamilienministerium wo es der 24 7
krisenstaat wo sind sie jeden tag
unterwegs und nicht nur einmal die woche
wie es aus dem hause zu hören war und
der künstler hat heute noch was schönes
gesagt ich darf noch mal zitieren auf
uns können sie sich verlassen hatte an
die ukraine gesagt mit einer woche
verspätung dann frage ich sie schon mal
warum ist dann immer noch der
ukrainische botschafter enttäuscht dass
aus berlin seit drei wochen keine
antwort kommt und an dieser stelle mal
ein riesen dankeschön an den
ukrainischen botschafter der wirklich
einen tollen job macht auch wenn er
beleidigt wird
einzelnen teilen der regierung oder der
medien der eine tolle arbeit macht aber
warum hat zum beispiel auch selensky auf
die frage dass vor 12 tagen gefragt
worden hat er gestern veröffentlicht
welche staats und regierungschefs er
schätzt mit welchen staats und
regierungschefs im täglichen austausch
ist warum länder dankbar warum nennt er
dann an der stelle beispielsweise auf
makro oder boris johnson warum denn der
die regierungschefs der baltischen
staaten
da muss der deutsche regierungs oft doch
dean antreten wenn es nicht macht heißt
es dass er sich auf uns nicht verlässt
und mit ihnen nicht in kontakt ist er
stolz
zum haushalt gibt es auch noch viel zu
sagen dieser haushalt ist ein haushalt
der nicht generationengerecht ist dieser
haushalt ist wirklich eine ganz ganz
große hypothek für die kommenden
generationen
wir erleben wirklich eine ganz große
umverteilung es wird alles auf dem
rücken der kinder ausgetragen und
deswegen sage ich ihnen das ist ja auch
vom kollegen nütze nicht angesprochen
worden dass es noch große verbesserungen
geben wird
das hoffe ich sehr für die kinder in
unserem land finden
[Applaus]
für die spd fraktion hat der kollege
auch hin kostet
frau präsidentin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir spüren doch alle
ich muss sagen fast alle dass das eine
ganz besondere debatte ist keine normale
generaldebatte sondern die erste
haushaltsdebatte nach der zeitenwende
und diese zeitenwende wurde markiert
durch den angriffskrieg durch den
aggressiven krieg von putin auf die
ukraine liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
das ist ein krieg ein angriff auf ein
großes land auf ein großes volk auf eine
große kulturnation
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das ist
ein angriff auf die menschlichkeit
und deshalb hat der bundeskanzler vor
dreieinhalb wochen hier in diesem hause
in diesem plenarsaal eine rede gehalten
die es in sich hat
die klug war die stark war die die
politischen koordinaten neu justiert hat
und die schon jetzt dinge verändert hat
die schon jetzt einiges verändert hat
und die in den nächsten wochen und
monaten und jahren noch vieles verändern
wird liebe kolleginnen und kollegen da
bin ich ganz sicher und ich will ihnen
ein sagen die
reaktionen die reaktionen in diesem haus
waren auch bemerkenswert die waren
nämlich überwiegend
weit überwiegend so dass der
sicherheitspolitische kompass denn der
bundeskanzler skizziert hat von fast
allen geteilt wurde und die waren weit
überwiegend so dass hier hier in diesem
hause bei dem angriffskrieg von putin
auf die ukraine zusammen stehen uns
zusammenhalten das ist keine
selbstverständlichkeit das ist ein hohes
gut das wir uns bewahren sollten in den
nächsten wochen und monaten liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und deshalb comic
zum sondervermögen das wurde ja
angesprochen zum sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr
selbstverständlich ist es so liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der cdu csu
dass die ampelkoalition mit ihnen
darüber redet wofür das geld ausgegeben
wird dass sie ihn mit ihnen darüber
redet wie man das zurückzahlen dass wir
mit ihnen darüber reden wie die
beschaffung modernisiert und reformiert
werden soll ist doch selbstverständlich
und ich hoffe doch sehr dass wir alle
über die sache reden denn der eine oder
andere der eine ist jetzt nicht mehr da
herr merz muss sich entscheiden was ihm
wichtiger ist staatstheater oder
staatsraison liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
und dann haben wir über den ergänzungs
haushaltgeräte des kollegen lindner
manche haben so getan als sei das
irgendwie geheim der
bundesfinanzminister hat sehr frühzeitig
dargelegt dass er einen ergänzungs
haushalt vorlegen will er hat sehr
frühzeitig dieses haus darüber
informiert dass er einen ergänzungs
haushalt vorlegen will und er hat sehr
frühzeitig auch die medien darüber
informiert was daran geheim oder einen
schattenhaushalt ist mir schleierhaft
das ist alles in ordnung genau so wie er
es gemacht hat deshalb unterstützt meine
fraktion den ergänzungs haushalt des
bundesfinanzministers und wir haben nur
hohle liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
viel zu tun oder will hier irgendjemand
die bundesbürgerinnen und bundesbürger
bei den hohen rasant ansteigenden
energiekosten nicht entlasten ich glaube
doch wohl kaum will hier irgendjemand
nichts dafür tun dass wir in die
energiesicherheit in deutschland
deutlich erhöhen und verbessern und will
hier irgendjemand was dafür nicht dafür
tun dass die flüchtlinge und unsere
kommunen mehr geld bekommen und klare
planungssicherheit für die nächsten
wochen und monate ich glaube nicht und
deshalb liebe kollegen und kollegen
fordern sie aber auch reden sie genau
wenn den ergänzungs haushalt vorliegt
dann können wir streiten dann können wir
diskutieren aber tun sie nicht so als
sei das eigene heim haushalt und eine
geheime diplomatische liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
zum bundeshaushalt sie können sich alle
die bürgerinnen und bürger dieses landes
darauf verlassen dass diese koalition
dass diese ampel koalition dass diese
bundesregierung
das was im koalitionsvertrag steht
umsetzt und zwar nicht nur bei den
schwerpunkten aber auch bei den
schwerpunkten mit mehr geld für
klimaschutz und digitalisierung mit mehr
geld für transformation und arbeit mit
mehr geld für einen funktionierenden
sozialstaat und auch mit mehr geld für
entwicklungszusammenarbeit hier haben
wir noch luft nach oben liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und lassen sie uns lassen sie uns am tag
vor dem europäischen rat am tag vor dem
gipfel auch über europa reden
denn all das was in deutschland was im
deutschen bundestag dass in der größten
volkswirtschaft europas diskutiert wird
ist auch von belang für euro für europa
und all das was wir hier besprechen
müssen wir europäisch einbetten deshalb
ist es gut und richtig liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen dass der bundeskanzler
gerade in den letzten wochen und monaten
nicht nur mit frankreich sondern mit all
unseren verbündeten der europäischen
union und darüber hinaus in gesprächen
ist und überlegt wie man aus dieser
krise heraus kommt denn diese krise
bietet auch möglichkeiten neue
möglichkeiten für eine
flüchtlingspolitik mit mehr solidarität
wir haben gerade darüber geredet was die
polen die ungarn die tschechen die
slowaken die moldawier die rumänen
leisten das ist nicht gering zu schätzen
das ist eine menge und dafür gibt wird
in unseren langen
und wir haben die chance in
europa die energiewende mit mehr mut
voranzubringen das wurde von vielen vor
inderinnen und vorrednern gesagt die
beste politik für mehr
unabhängigkeit nicht nur von russischem
gas nicht nur von russischer steinkohle
nicht nur von russischem erdöl sondern
grundsätzlich ist der beschleunigte
ausbau von erneuerbaren energien liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und deshalb ist es richtig die
europäische union kann aufbauen auf
einem starken fundament für
zukunftsinvestitionen durch den
wiederaufbau vor und wir machen es
richtig wenn wir den nationalstaaten
luft zum atmen geben deswegen war es
richtig den stabilitäts und
wachstumspakt in diesem jahr noch
auszusetzen und ich finde es vernünftig
dass die europäische kommission überlegt
wie man mit dieser ukraine krise in den
nächsten monaten und jahren umgehen denn
eins ist doch klar liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen all das was wir heute
besprochen haben all das was wir in den
nächsten wochen und monaten machen
wollen kann am besten
diese bundesregierung dieser
bundeskanzler denn sie agieren
entschlossen und besonnen und ich hoffe
ich würde hoffen dass man das wort allen
in diesem hause so sagen konnte liebe
kollegen und überlegen und deshalb bin
ich froh dass dieser bundeskanzler in
diesen schwierigen zeiten dieses land
regiert alle anderen finde ich nicht so
gut schön danken
das war es der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der
spd-bundestagsfraktion
der bundestag ist hinter dem rathaus
als des bundeskanzlers dazu gehört auch
die kulturen markierungen von der hd er
ist der kulturpolitische sprecher hat
jetzt das tier im hause
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
kunst politik sollte kunst nicht
beurteilen oder gar durch vorgaben
versuchen zu instrumentalisieren
politik muss kunst den rücken freihalten
zitat ende das schrieben sie frau roth
2018 in ihrer brüsseler erklärung für
die freiheit der kunst und diese worte
kann ich zu 100 prozent unterschreiben
aber was machen sie heute sie richten
einen green culture des kein eine
zentrale beratungs und vernetzungsstelle
für den ökologischen umbau der kultur
100 millionen euro wollen sie von den
grünen den nächsten drei jahren am
liebsten dafür ausgeben green
consultants sollen ausgebildet werden
die die kulturinstitutionen
flächendeckend beraten über monitoring
und reporting man beachteten kultur
kultur fremden business sprech müssen
diese institutionen bericht erstatten
über ihre fortschritte in sachen
nachhaltigkeit bitte werfen sie den
regierungen in ungarn polen oder
österreich nie wieder vor die
kreativszene für ihre zwecke
instrumentalisieren zu wollen das ist
pure heuchelei werte grünen frau roth
sie machen genau das was sie den anderen
scheinheilig vorwerfen bei dieser green
culture geht es nicht nur um
energetische gebäudesanierung co2
reduzierung und ähnliches das ist nur
der anfang schon jetzt steht im
haushaltsentwurf es wird neben
umweltthemen auch die
geschlechtergerechtigkeit gefördert also
quoten für frauen für migranten für
sexuelle minderheiten
bekenntnis zwang zu vielfalt toleranz
und weltoffenheit und vor allem gegen
rechts sprich gegenpositionen die vor
kurzem noch bürgerlicher common sense
war das ist es was sie der kultur
zwangsweise verordnen wollen das ist das
gegenteil von freiheit und
über allem schwebt der klimaschutz wie
eine art heilige monstranz dem sich alle
zu unterwerfen haben dem die kultur zu
dienen hat die ironie dabei ist alle
ihre klimamaßnahmen zusammen werden das
weltklima nicht um ein hundertstel grad
beeinflussen dafür sind sie im
weltmaßstab eben viel zu marginal
sie führen angst und schuldgefühle bei
den bürgern und vor allem war der jugend
um sich dann selbst als die retter und
erlöser
anzubieten von problemen die sich selbst
erst maßlos aufgebauscht haben und ganz
ähnlich gehen sie ja bei corona vor die
horrenden schäden im kulturbereich diese
jetzt mit krokodilstränen beklagen die
haben sie doch durch ihre überzogenen
maßnahmen selbst herbeigeführt und die
dienen jetzt dazu die kultur noch
abhängiger zu machen von staatlichen
zuwendungen und da mit formbarer und
worauf das alles hinausläuft dass wird
ausgeplaudert vom aktionsnetzwerk
nachhaltigkeit einer von der wk einem
geförderten
initiative ich zitiere von der homepage
dort den meisten handelnden akteurinnen
ist klar dass der prozess der erneuerung
auch das beenden von altem bedeuten muss
ein green deal muss daher genauso
innovativ und jetzt kommt die palliativ
gedacht sein zitat ende welche kultur
soll denn hier zu grabe getragen werden
meine damen und herren es sind die reste
der bürgerlichen hochkultur und der
christlich-abendländischen kultur lauter
werke alter weißer männer die entsorgt
werden können darum wollen sie die
stiftung preußischer kulturbesitz
zerschlagen darum sind ihnen die burg
die bibelworte auf der kuppel des
berliner stadtschlosses ein dorn im auge
und dazu passt ich komme zu dem schluss
dass die integrationsbeauftragte der
bundesregierung der deutschen
mehrheitsgesellschaft bei jeder
gelegenheit alltagsrassismus unterstellt
vor bali radio waren wenn sie einmal den
islamistischen anschlag vom
breitscheidplatz genau so wortreich
beklagen und gegenmaßnahmen ankündigen
wie den anschlag von hanau dann nehme
ich ihnen ihre betroffenheit ab bis
dahin gilt für sie gibt es rassismus nur
in eine richtung das ist nicht
glaubwürdig sie betreiben eine
durchschaubare
klientel-politik die fdp-fraktion wer
sich dem weiterhin entschieden
entgegenstellen vielen dank
seit heute morgen um neuen gerät der
deutsche bundestag am zweiten tag seine
haushaltsberatungen den etat des bundes
kannst das das ist traditionell die
große aussprache über die politik der
bundesregierung die generaldebatte und
ich bin ich sehr reger jetzt hier in
dieser debatte ist andrea
andreas rippert
aber von den bündnisgrünen ist mitglied
im prozess ausschuss präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren wir verhandeln
diesen haushalt heute und in den
kommenden wochen in einer zeit voller
krisen putins angriff zwingt viele
menschen auf die flucht darunter sind
auch viele kulturschaffende viele
medienschaffende und auch in russland
das ist die zweite seite der gleichen
medaille sind viele kulturschaffende die
dort unterdrückt werden die fliehen
müssen die sich auf den weg machen und
die ins exil gehen müssen
meinungsfreiheit freie medien freie
kultur all das sind machtvolle
instrumente das sieht man in genau
diesen zeiten da sieht man wenn man sich
anschaut was dort passiert menschen wie
swetlana alexijewitsch die
nobelpreisträgerin oder der journalist
yahoo maximovitsch für den ich eine
patenschaft übernommen habe müssen
fliehen werden eingesperrt werden
verfolgt und bedroht sie alle haben
unsere unterstützung verdient
[Applaus]
sofortige hilfe für geflüchtete ist das
was wir jetzt brauchen und spezielle
programme für medien und
kulturschaffende wir brauchen exil
programme und wir brauchen programme die
diese stimmen und das sind nicht nur
stimmen sondern das den scharfe
schwerter auch in der auseinandersetzung
mit diktatoren wie wladimir putin dass
diese stimmen der demokratie und der
freiheit nicht verstummen und gerade
jetzt in dieser zeit nicht verstanden
und wenn wir bei uns schauen hier in
deutschland dann merken wir dass
autoritäres denken dass großmacht
fantasien sich auch hier bei uns und
auch hier im deutschen bundestag breit
machen wenn wir aufgehört haben was der
kollege der jungen gesagt hat dann
erinnert das an das was er die ganzen
letzten jahre verbreitet nämlich das
theater das kultur sich in deutschland
nur noch an den zwölf jahren des dritten
reiches abarbeiten würde und dass alle
diejenigen die diesen großmacht
fantasien nicht folgen gelder gekürzt
werden müssen das ist das was wir dort
sehen beim die autoritären denken tut
dienst und an anderer stelle und was wir
hier sondern es wird noch schlimmer
alexander gauland war 2015 in sankt
petersburg und hat den russischen
rechtsextremen den vordenker dort
alexander dugin getroffen ihre
verbindungen genau dorthin sind
elementar sind im detail belegt und das
ist das was wir hier erleben und was wir
beantworten müssen mit viel klarheit mit
unmissverständlichkeit wir machen eine
kulturpolitik für die freiheit des
denkens für die freiheit der meinung für
die vielfalt und das ist die art wie wir
darauf antworten und ich möchte das
konkret machen ich möchte das konkret
machen wir investieren in maßnahmen
gegen rechtsextremismus in maßnahmen
gegen rassismus wir arbeiten die
koloniale vergangenheit auf wir starten
die deutsche welle anständig mit geld
aus wir geben geld an das jüdische
museum was zusätzliche mittel erhält und
wir sorgen auch dafür dass der etat der
staatsministerin und beauftragte gegen
rassismus für antirassismus ramallah
bali radovan anständig ausgestattet wird
dass wir hier für eine offene
gesellschaft gemeinsam kämpfen für
freiheiten vielfalt das ist unsere
politik und dafür stehen wir gemeinsam
ein
viele
kulturschaffende haben in den
vergangenen jahren der pandemie
besonders gelitten
und was mich beeindruckt hat in der zeit
ist dass es gerade diese
kulturschaffenden waren die immer wieder
solidarität gezeigt haben die immer
wieder solidarisch wert waren und was
das für uns auch als politik bedeuten
muss ist dass diese solidarität
beidseitig sein muss deswegen werden wir
das programm neustart kultur fortführen
und wir werden die künstlersozialkasse
anständig finanzieren ich weiß was es
bedeutet wenn man die sicherheit im
leben nicht hat die man braucht um seine
arbeit zu machen und wir sorgen dafür
dass es im kulturbereich nicht der fall
ist
in letzter
aber zentraler punkt die
klimakatastrophe duldet keinen aufschub
und deswegen stellen wir auch dieses
thema in den mittelpunkt unserer
kulturpolitik der green culture desk ist
angesprochen werden worden wir machen
das jetzt wir stellen geld dafür ein und
sorgen dafür dass auch die kulturbranche
an dieser stelle ihren beitrag leisten
kann und wir wissen wie sehr sie das
wollen auch in der stadt stelle arbeiten
wir zusammen ich freue mich auf die
beratungen claudia roth und ich freue
mich auf die beratung mit ihnen vielen
dank
[Applaus]
das wort hat der kollege thomas hacker
für die fdp
thomas hacker ist der medienpolitischen
sprecher der fdp-bundestagsfraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die politik
kann man keine kultur machen vielleicht
kann man mit kulturpolitik machen das
sind worte des früheren
bundespräsidenten theodor heuss ja es
stimmt politik kann keine kultur machen
kultur aber auch die medien sind immer
etwas eigenes etwas einzigartiges ist
abbild spiegelbild und brennglas der
debatten unserer zeit sie beeinflussen
und prägen unsere gesellschaft zu
berühren und verändern menschen und
meinungen sie sind lebenselixier für
unsere demokratische gesellschaft als
andere koalition sind wir mit einem
bekenntnis zur vielfalt in kultur medien
angetreten wollen kultur mit allen und
für alle ermöglichen ihre freiheit
sichern mit kulturellen und
künstlerischen im kurzen den
gesellschaftlichen aufbruch befördern
und neue debatten räume schaffen aber
kultur medien brauchen auch die
richtigen rahmenbedingungen und hier ist
die politik gefordert die korona
pandemie hat uns auch gezeigt wie
unverzichtbar musik theater tanz oder
kino für uns erlebens sind und heute
erleben wir in der ukraine
das unvorstellbare menschen kämpfen um
ihr leben und der krieg zwingt sie zur
flucht
kultur mit allen zu ermöglichen ist auch
verpflichtung menschen auf der flucht
einzubinden und ihnen hierzulande
kreatives und journalistisches arbeiten
zu ermöglichen unser bekenntnis zur
kultur medienvielfalt drückt sich auch
in einer volkswirtschaftlich schwierigen
zeit durch einen spürbaren mittel
aufrufs auf und dafür bin ich
finanzminister christian lindner und
kulturstaatsministerin claudia roth sehr
dankbar und liebe frau bär wenn es was
zu logen gibt dann kann man auch loben
wir wollen
wir wollen den herausforderungen der
gegenwart begegnen den kreativen und
kulturschaffenden den weg aus der
pandemie ebnen wir müssen die deutsche
welle stärken damit sie im
informationskrieg bestehen kann
programme in russischer und bela
russischer sprache ausbaut und darüber
nachdenken die russischsprachige
faktenbasierte angebote auch
russischsprachige zielgruppen bei uns im
inland erreichen klar ist die stärkung
der programme und die notwendigen
technischen die personellen ausstattung
in kosten geld das ist aber unumgänglich
im interesse unserer europäischen werte
es sind investitionen auch in unsere
freiheit
russische journalistinnen und
journalisten brauchen unsere
unterstützung damit sie schnell
arbeitslose erhalten ihre arbeit hier in
deutschland fortsetzen können
unabhängige russische informationen für
die bevölkerung russlands das ist wofür
wir uns einsetzen
eine freie gesellschaft muss auch um
ihre eigene vergangenheit und
verantwortung wissen die bundesstiftung
für aufarbeitung leistet hier
hervorragende arbeit sie ist
anlaufstelle für der institution und
katalysator
zivilgesellschaftlichen engagement ihre
handlungsfähigkeit zu stärken stärkt den
zusammenhalt in unserer gesellschaft und
wir müssen wege finden die
kulturschaffenden aus der ukraine zu
unterstützen in den zuflucht sicherheit
und aufstiegsmöglichkeiten zu geben
gleiches gilt aber auch für die
künstlerischen die künstlerinnen
künstler aus russland und belarus die
putins krieg eben nicht unterstützen und
deswegen unseren respekt und unsere
hilfe brauchen er war bereit des krieges
können wir nur gemeinsam begegnen kultur
hilft gräben zu überwinden und menschen
zusammenzuführen und genau deswegen kann
man mit kulturpolitik machen vielen dank
[Applaus]
das wort hat der kollege jürgen hardt
für die cdu/csu-fraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich möchte zu den außen- und
sicherheitspolitischen themen sprechen
aber ich möchte trotzdem an das
anknüpfen was in der unter den
kulturschaffenden dieses bundestages
eben gerade gesagt wurde ich finde wir
haben ein leistungsfähiges instrument
eine starke stimme der freien welt die
von uns aus von deutschland aus ins
ausland die freie meinung schlägt und
unsere position und die position der
freien welt verkündet das ist die
deutsche welle und ich glaube dass wir
alle gemeinsam auch als eine konsequenz
aus der erfahrung der letzten monate mit
der wachsenden unfreiheit auch hier bei
uns in europa mit der aggression durch
russland aber auch mit dem was in china
hervorgeht alle gemeinsam dafür sorgen
müssen dass deutsche welle ihren auftrag
noch besser erfüllen kann also dass
bereits schon tut und ich finde dass wir
darüber hinaus auch darüber nachdenken
müssen wie wir den falschinformationen
und den fake facts die auch in unser
land hinein strahlen zum beispiel in
russischer sprache konsequent etwas
entgegenhalten damit nicht die
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger die aus
alter gewohnheit und aus sprachkompetenz
eben doch stark russische medien
konsumieren von diesen falschen
behauptungen über räumt werden und eben
keine chance haben sich das bild richtig
zu rücken deswegen brauche ich hab auch
lebt habe ich in deutschland eine auch
eine nationale anstrengung der
überwindung von facts das ist mein
beitrag zur kultur abteilung der
heutigen debatte und ansonsten möchte
ich anknüpfen an das was wir zum thema
russland überfall auf die ukraine gesagt
haben wir haben gegenüber den
bundeskanzler der bundesregierung
erklärt durch unseren
fraktionsvorsitzenden heute bekräftigt
und wiederholt dass wir die notwendige
politik als konsequenz aus der
zeitenwende die wir leben unterstützen
das bedeutet aber nicht dass wir bereit
sind alles kritiklos hinzunehmen sondern
im gegenteil dass wir konstruktiv
unserer eigenen vorschläge dazu machen
und es gibt eine frage die für mich über
allen debatten dieser tage steht das ist
die frage tun wir genug um die ukraine
zu unterstützen das ist die frage die
auch letzten donnerstag hier als der
ukrainische präsident zielinski zu uns
gesprochen hat im raum stand und er
kommt zu der bitteren aussage dass wir
aus seiner sicht aus der sicht der
ukraine nicht genug tun um die ukraine
zu unterstützen jetzt kann man zu dieser
aussage unterschiedliche meinungen haben
aber es wäre natürlich gut gewesen wird
die bundesregierung in der bundeskanzler
sowohl gegenüber der ukrainischen als
auch gegenüber der deutschen
öffentlichkeit dass hier klar gestellt
hätte was wir tun warum wir bestimmte
dinge nämlich konkrete nato einmischung
in diesem krieg im ablehnen aber
ansonsten natürlich an der seite der
ukraine stehen diese chance ist leider
nicht erfolgt und ich kann auch leider
aus meiner perspektive
nicht ganz den eindruck den präsidenten
sg hat qualitäten nicht genug entkräften
denn es gibt zwei wesentliche felder auf
denen wir gehen das eine könnte sein die
verstärkung der militärhilfe für die
ukraine dort gibt es die verschiedensten
weg es gibt zum einen die frage was hat
die bundeswehr was wir gegebenenfalls
aus dem bestand abgeben können es gibt
zum zweiten die frage was kann die
deutsche industrie
kurzfristig liefern wo dann
entsprechende ausfuhrgenehmigung zu
erteilen sind im übrigen auch die frage
zu klären ist wer das bezahlt und es
gibt drittens
ausländische partner nationen die
deutsche waffen in ihrem bestand haben
die sie nicht ohne weiteres an andere
länder abgeben dürfen ohne unsere
einverständnis zu all diesen drei fragen
ist die bundesregierung gefordert
kurzfristige entscheidungen zu treffen
und wir hören jetzt seit tagen dass man
dies unter geheimhaltung tun will und
dass man einen weg findet den deutschen
bundestag zu unterrichten wir als
mitglieder des auswärtigen ausschusses
ich glaube die kollegen im
verteidigungsausschuss sehen das ähnlich
haben leider noch nicht ausreichend
informationen in der geheimschutzstelle
des deutschen bundestag was konkret
geliefert dessen wir können deswegen
auch nicht gegenhalten wenn wir vorwürfe
aus der ukraine oder von anderswo
gekommen und das ist sehr schade weil es
uns image schadet unabhängig davon ob
man das jetzt im einzelnen fall
widerlegen kann da nicht jetzt ist
einfach eine vertane chance für uns
deutschland das zweite ist dass wir
natürlich bei der frage der
sanktionspolitik auch fahrer die
bundesregierung haben konkret was die
umsetzung angeht brauchen wir in
deutschland möglicherweise einer
verschärfung der gesetze um
sanktionspolitik im land konkret gegen
personen umzusetzen oder brauchen wir
das nicht auch diese fragen sind
weiterhin unbeantwortet ich glaube dass
die cdu csu fraktion bereit wäre
gegebenenfalls notwendige
gesetzesänderungen zur durchsetzung von
sanktionen zu beschließen aber es ist
nunmal nicht unsere sache jetzt zu
entscheiden darüber ob das notwendig ist
aber wir sehen doch große defizite und
das dritte was meines erachtens auch von
der regierung kommen müsste und wozu der
bundeskanzler heute die gelegenheit
gehabt hätte dass hier vielleicht zu tun
was folgt eigentlich aus der kommt aus
dem krieg der ukraine der und der russen
gegen die ukraine was folgt aus dem
klick putins gegen die ukraine für
unsere strategische gesamtaufstellung es
land ja nicht dass wir uns in den
tagesaktuellen herausforderungen
beschäftigen sondern wir müssen ja
darüber hinaus gehen was bedeutet das
für unsere europäische energie
sicherheitsstrategie was bedeutet das
für uns westbalkan politik wo wir als
europäische union deutschland mit dabei
doch sehr zögerlich mit den aufnahmen
prozessen was bedeutet das gegenüber
unserer haltung gegenüber serbien
serbien will in die europäische union
gleichzeitig der ministerpräsident von
serben gajic
entsprechend auf den trip für ist eine
schaukel politik zwischen russland und
europa zu betreiben wo seit wo die
waagschale manchmal sehr stark richtung
russland zeigt da müssen wir klare
ansagen machen insbesondere bei den
serben er in kürze wahlen sind das
erwarte ich auch von der bundesregierung
ich glaube dass wir uns auch ein blick
auf die einsätze die wir in afrika
machen in der saal zone klar sein müssen
es geht nicht nur um die stabilisierung
der sahel zone und der regierung dort
und die befriedung abwehr von
terrorismus es geht auch um die frage
wie sind eigentlich andere russland und
china in diesen teilen afrikas unterwegs
und mit welchen zielen und mitmenschen 3
die malische regierung genau wie andere
regierungen der region vertraut
offensichtlich mehr auf bezahlt da
sollte noch von putin als auch reguläre
truppen auf der basis von un oder eu
einsetzen auch da glaube ich muss die
bundesregierung uns eine antwort geben
auch die handelspolitik ist ein
wichtiges feld ich kann mich erinnern
dass die damalige
bundeswirtschaftsminister gabriel spd
hier verkündet hat sieht könnte man zwar
machen aber tipp das ginge nicht das war
ein ganz großer fehler das war eine
steilvorlage für den amerikanischen
präsidenten kramp das dann hinterher
tatsächlich zu knicken ich glaube dass
wir den mut und das engagement haben
sollten in der hand auch die
handelspolitik als teil unserer und zwar
ganz konkreten abwehrpolitik gegen
diktatorisches und aggressives verhalten
anderer einzusetzen
das gilt meines erachtens auch für die
frage wie wir mit china umgehen ich
fürchte dass wir mit china den nächsten
autokratischen diktatorischen
gegenüber in der weltpolitik haben den
wir uns gemeinsam erwehren müssen und
ich glaube dass die bundesregierung
dringend beraten ist über die lösung der
alltags herausforderung hinaus auch auf
diese mittel und langfristigen
strategischen fragen antworten zu geben
und in diesem sinne freue ich mich
darauf dass wir vielleicht diese sagt
die dinge doch noch besprechen dass wir
das gemeinsam hier im parlament
diskutieren und dass wir damit dazu
beitragen dass wir insgesamt als
demokraten eine bessere zukunft schaffen
als das was wir heute im frühjahr des
jahres 2000 2020 22 leider vorfinden in
diesem sinne herzlichen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
der sprecher für auswärtige politik
irgend hat hierfür die unionsfraktion in
der generaldebatte hat hier einen
kleinen rundumschlag zur ukraine krise
gemacht die bundesregierung auch dafür
kritisiert dass sie nicht ausreichend
position bezogen
simona koß spricht jetzt für die spd
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
in zeiten von internationaler
desinformation und in zeiten putins
einriss kriegs auf die ukraine zeigt
sich eine offene und pluralistische
gesellschaft ist wichtiger denn je und
ebenso eine gesellschaft wird oder la
viel zeit
unser
sozialdemokratisches credo für den
kulturbereich kultur für alle setzt
zeichen und macht einen aufbruch in der
kulturpolitik möglich mit diesem
haushalt setzen wir das um was wir uns
im koalitionsvertrag
vorgenommen haben dafür stellen wir im
haushalt für das jahr 2022
2,1 milliarden euro zur verfügung gut
investiertes geld meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren wir
werden kultur als staatsziel im
grundgesetz verankern
mit einem kultur plenum wollen wir ein
zukunft dialog kultur schaffen und dabei
kommunen länder
bund und kultur akteurinnen sowie
vertreter innen der zivilgesellschaft
einbeziehen lassen sie mich im folgenden
auf einige kulturpolitische aspekte die
meiner fraktion als besonders wichtig
sind eingehen wir werden die
kulturförderung des bundes weiter
entwickeln und hierbei die
kulturstiftung des bundes und die
förderfonds stärken
die korona pandemie hat gezeigt wie
wichtig eine verbesserte absicherung von
solo selbstständigen in der
künstlersozialkasse ist aus diesem grund
wollen wir für eine bessere soziale
absicherung der kultur und
medienschaffenden sorgen
wir treten ein für mindesten und
ausstellungs honorare und wir werden die
arbeitslosenversicherung zu einer
arbeits versicherung weiter entwickeln
so dass sie auch der freiwilligen
versicherung gegen einnahmeausfälle
offen steht
weiterhin werden wir die filmförderung
durch eine novellierung des
filmförderungsgesetzes
weiterentwickeln und mit einem
zukunftsprogramm kino das kino als
kulturellen begegnungsort insbesondere
in ländlichen regionen stärken
weiterhin ist es uns wichtig die
erinnerungskultur voranzubringen und die
entwicklung einer postkolonialen
erinnerungskultur zu fördern wir werden
wir werden und das liegt mir sehr am
herzen das denkmal zur mahnung und
erinnerung an die opfer der
kommunistischen diktatur in deutschland
nun endlich auf den weg bringen
und meine damen und herren wir fördern
orte deutscher demokratie geschichte wie
zb das hambacher schloss die frankfurter
paulskirche und das haus der weimarer
republik
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
ich sprach eingangs von der bedeutung
der stärkung der presse und
medienfreiheit
aus diesem grund verstärken wir den
kampf gegen hetze und desinformationen
wir werden journalistinnen und
journalisten im in und ausland mit
besseren sozialen und wirtschaftlichen
rahmenbedingungen zur seite stehen ich
danke an dieser stelle all denen
korrespondentinnen und korrespondenten
die uns unter einsatz ihres lebens aus
der ukraine mit informationen versorgen
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
wir stärken mit diesem haushalt die
deutsche welle als botschafterin
deutschlands in der welt nie war sie so
wertvoll wie heute ihr etat wächst von
363 millionen euro im jahr
2021 auf
361 millionen euro in diesem jahr
zum schluss sei erwähnt dass wir
selbstverständlich die umfangreichen und
gut wirkenden corona hilfsprogramme für
kultur und medien schaffende auch im
jahr 2022 fortsetzen und damit einen
wichtigen beitrag zur erhaltung unserer
kultur und medien landschaft leisten
ich freue mich auf die zusammenarbeit
bei den beratungen und danke ihnen für
die aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
die
spd-fraktion und es folgt ein
koalitionspartner der sozialdemokraten
für die grünen spricht jetzt gerhard
gründe der kultur und medienpolitische
sprecher seiner fraktion
auch präsidentin meine damen und herren
ich möchte meine drei minuten einem
einzigen punkt widmen wenn krieg nicht
mehr klick heißen kann wenn das wort
invasion in bezug auf den überfall
russlands auf die ukraine bei androhung
von bis zu 15 jahren haft nicht benutzt
werden darf dann ist das das ende von
meinungsfreiheit von pressefreiheit das
ist es was wir im krieg gegen die
ukraine gerade erleben dieser krieg ist
auch ein krieg um die meinungshoheit und
damit ein krieg gegen journalistinnen
und journalisten gegen einen freien
öffentlichen diskurs und gegen eine
kritische zivilgesellschaft es zeigt wie
fundamental wichtig die freie presse und
wie sehr wird wie wichtig die freie
presse ist und wie sehr totalitäre
regime sie fürchten von zehn jahren
haben nadeshda tore nico war maria alm
china und katharina sagen cilic drei
junge russinnen besser bekannt unter
ihrem bandnamen passiert folgendes
gesungen ich zitiere mit erlaubnis der
präsidentin muttergottes verlage putin
alle gemeindemitglieder kriechen zur
verbeugung das phantom der freiheit ist
im himmel homosexuelle werden in ketten
nach sibirien geschickt der kgb chef ihr
oberster heiliger er wirft die
demonstranten in scharen ins gefängnis
um den höchsten nicht zu beleidigen
müssen frauen gebären und lieben mutter
gottes werde feministin zitat ende für
diese zeilen sind die
drei frauen zwei jahre ins arbeitslager
geschickt worden von putins justiz
dieser abscheuliche schuldspruch zeigte
jedem und jeder wie sehr diktatoren die
freiheit der kunst fürchten die bittere
wahrheit ist wir haben damals zugeschaut
wir haben business as usual versehen
vielleicht mit einer kleinen protestnote
amerikas weiter gemacht dass meine damen
und herren darf uns nie wieder passieren
inzwischen sind in russland den letzten
unabhängigen medien verboten worden
facebook und twitter wurden
eingeschränkt aber natürlich kennt putin
letztendlich wie alle diktatoren einen
aussichtslosen kampf die zahl der
menschen in russland wächst die diese
verbote mitbekommen und die der
monopolistischen staatspropaganda
misstrauen russische journalist innen
haben gelernt kreativ mit der repression
umzugehen und verbote gegebenenfalls zu
umgehen sie erfinden sich immer wieder
neue etwa die nowaja gaseta oder marina
auch senken die koffer die mit einem
plakat im staatsfernsehen gegen den
krieg protestiert hier werdet ihr
belogen das stand auf dem schild das
sind die wahren russischen heldinnen in
putins angriffskrieg was diese leute
machen ist kreativ und es ist wie sie
selbst gefährlich und ich verbeuge mich
hier am rednerpult in diesem hohen hause
in demut vor dem mut dieser menschen es
reicht aber nicht hier das loblied auf
die mutigen leute in russlands
anzustimmen es ist entscheidend was wir
für uns in den kommenden wochen die
richtigen konsequenzen ziehen wir müssen
als deutscher bundestag dafür einstehen
dass die kunstfreiheit und die
unabhängige presse als das eingestuft
werden was sie sind die entscheidenden
voraussetzungen für unser leben in
freiheit umso wichtiger ist das
soforthilfeprogramm für geflohene
ukrainische künstlerinnen der
staatskultur mit kulturstaatsministerin
für das zunächst eine million euro zur
verfügung stehen wird
putins propaganda benutzt auch das wort
vom befreiung aber ich habe die
geflüchteten aus der ukraine gesehen und
ich konnte auch mit einigen von ihnen
sprechen sie fliehen nicht vor befreien
sie fliehen vor denen die sie unter
jochen wollen und die ihre freiheit mit
panzern und bomben brechen wollen meine
damen und herren das pfand gebet von
pussy wright wird noch da sein wenn der
diktator längst geschichte ist das ist
die macht der freiheit der kunst
lassen sie uns über die starke
das wort hat der kollege stefan seidler
stefan seiler ist fraktionslos war vom
südschleswigschen wählerverband
bundestag gewählt wurde
staatsministerin roth der
südschleswigsche wählerverband er ist es
wie es zum ersten mal seit 60 jahren
wieder im bundestag vertreten
das ist an sich ein großer erfolg doch
die mitglieder
die mitglieder des ssw haben diesen
großen schritt nicht aus einer
nordischen laune heraus gewagt sondern
weil wir uns nicht länger tag oder weil
man nicht länger tatenlos bleiben können
es muss sich etwas ändern
für die heimischen minderheiten hier in
deutschland aber auch für den norden
insgesamt es wurde viel über kultur
gesprochen erlauben sie mir in dieser
generaldebatte mit vielen großen fragen
in diesem teilbereich ganz tief
einzutauchen die projektförderung für
die friesischen volksgruppe soll sinken
welches signal sendet dass den friesen
doch nicht nur die kürzung sind ein
problem die struktur ist es ebenfalls
den gelder gibt es nur im rahmen von
projektförderung davon müssen wir
wegkommen und hin zu einer dauerhaften
nicht projekt gebundenen förderung der
nationalen minderheiten meine damen nur
so schafft man planungssicherheit
stabilität und vertrauen so wie es jetzt
ist können die leute keine dauerhaften
arbeitsverträge unterzeichnen und müssen
teils kredite aufnehmen um die zeit bis
zur projekt mit fördermitteln freigabe
zu überbrücken das geht so nicht
friesische kultur ist kein projekt in
deutschland sondern ein stetiger teil
unserer gesellschaft
dringend werden auch gelder benötigt für
den dachverband der dänischen minderheit
die pandemie insgesamt hat freizeit
sport und kultur leben sowie das
ehrenamt hart getroffen minderheiten hat
ist umso härter getroffen deswegen sind
einrichtungen die kulturellen
einrichtung der minderheit nur umso
wichtiger für unsere gesellschaft und in
ihren zusammenhalt und müssen gerade
jetzt gefördert werden die
bundesförderung für die dänische
minderheit ist seit 20 jahren nicht mehr
aufgestockt und an den bedürfnissen
angepasst worden sehr geehrte
staatsminister in roth sorgen sie dafür
dass das vielfältige kulturelle leben
auch der minderheiten in unserem land
weiter bestand hat wie erfahren gerade
schmerzhaft wie verwundbar freiheit und
demokratie in europa sind
stärken können wir unsere deutsche
demokratie wenn mehrheit auf die
minderheiten zu geht ihnen anerkennung
und unterstützung zuteil werden lässt in
europa darf nicht das recht der
stärkeren gelten sowie putin es gerade
versucht sondern das verständnis für den
anderen 400
stefan seidler bades im bereich des
kanzleramt assist auch der bereich des
beauftragten der bundesregierung für
ostdeutschland und linda teuteberg
wird nun als nächste sprechen sie ist
abgeordnete aus brandenburg
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen dass der beauftragte der
bundesregierung für ostdeutschland
inzwischen beim kanzleramt angesiedelt
ist finde ich es eine gute entscheidung
und zwar nicht so sehr weil nicht auch
einfach besser und das war ja vorher das
bundesministerium für wirtschaft gute
arbeit machen könnte und sich den
anliegen annehmen könnte sondern
deswegen weil es kein rein ökonomisches
anliegen ist die innere einheit unseres
landes die seine querschnittsaufgabe und
allein deshalb ist das richtig so sehr
so sehr übrigens bill clinton einmal mit
seinem ausspruch ist die economy stupid
in mancherlei hinsicht recht hatte
wirtschaft es wahrlich wichtig ist sie
nicht alles und insofern auch mit
manchen nicht gerne hören wollen sage
ich auch aus dem osten unseres landes
kommt noch mal viele der strukturellen
nachhaltigen wirtschaftlichen probleme
auch fragen von eigentums
vermögensverteilung die ligen an den
jahren vor 1989 und nicht an denen
danach es lohnt sich daran zu denken
denn in diesen tagen vor 50 jahren da
wurden die letzten privaten
familienunternehmen aus deutschland
verstaatlicht 11.000 betriebe gab es
noch und am 13 juli 1972 meldete erich
honecker und breschnew den abschluss der
verstaatlichungs kampagne da liegen die
grundlagen und noch viel früher der
probleme die wir heute zum teil noch
haben und es ist gut dass manche
durchgehalten haben und nach der
wiedervereinigung wieder investiert
haben oder das unternehmen in dem sie
vorher als angestellter im eigenen
betrieb tätig sein durften wiederbelebt
haben ich nenne nur beispiele die sika
werke in leipzig die firma grad in halle
oder schoko orgelbau in potsdam aber sie
stehen für viele und insofern
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir unser
land durch eine brille der unterschiede
betrachtet der wird zwangsläufig immer
irgendwo in himmelsrichtungen spaltungen
erkennen aber es gibt viele themen die
sind für unser ganzes land wichtig es
ist die frage von gleichwertigen nicht
gleichen aber gleichwertigen
lebensverhältnissen in stadt und land es
sind die fragen von mobilität bildung
chancen demographie und fachkräften und
die beschäftigen viele regionen in
unserem land der osten unseres landes
der sollte sich darauf konzentrieren
finde ich eigene stärken zu entwickeln
und auszubauen statt andere regionen zu
kopieren und wir haben da stärken
nämlich eine starke
wissenschaftslandschaft und die
verkehrsinfrastruktur
werden aber in ganz deutschland einiges
daran zu tun unser planungs und
genehmigungsrecht zu vereinfachen davon
würde die ganze republik profitieren
aber gerade auch aus deutschland unser
planungs und genehmigungsrecht es muss
ein mögliches recht werden in
generationen denken aber endlich und
überschaubaren zeit und der ließ was mir
aber jetzt besonders wichtig ist ist
dass wir viel mehr brauchen
gesamtdeutsche debatten schon im
allgemeinen und jetzt ganz besonders
über unser geschichtsbild was ist
eigentlich unsere historische
verantwortung auch gegenüber unseren
nachbarn in europa und ich sage dass
hier nicht um irgendwelche kritik ohne
grund zu üben oder aus hellen aber mich
hat es bestimmt was in den letzten
jahren los war zum teil als durch mein
bundesland zum beispiel nato-truppen
transporte 2017 stattfanden weil die
polen und balten darum gebeten haben
nachdem was los war der annexion der
krim den ereignissen in georgien da hat
der ministerpräsident zum beispiel eines
bundeslandes wie sich heutige die drei
routen wirklich verteidigt gegen die
überziehung in sicherheit als
befindlichkeiten disqualifiziert hier
sollten deutlich machen wir werden
gemeinsam außenpolitisch und
sicherheitspolitisch erwachsenen wir
machen außen und sicherheitspolitik mit
und nicht gegen unsere nachbarn vielen
dank
der ukraine spielt natürlich in der
generaldebatte hier eine rolle auch wenn
in diesem etat des bundeskanzlers
verschiedene thematiken abgebildet wird
wie eben aus deutschland aber zum
beispiel auch kultur und medien sepp
müller spricht jetzt stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der union
präsidentin meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren der fürchterliche
angriffskrieg in der ukraine und die
europäische union näher zusammen der
fürchterliche angriffskrieg in der
ukraine rückt den osten deutschlands
mehr und im mittelpunkt hinter uns
liegen 16 erfolgreiche jahre der
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel die den
osten deutschlands zum standort der
zukunftstechnologie hat werden lassen
und
die bundeskanzler sie wollen ja das zur
chefsache machen da ist es auch gut dass
sie da sind schade der zuständige
staatsminister herr schneider heute
nicht anwesend ist das ist eine
respektlosigkeit gegenüber den osten das
sieht wie die priorität in ihrem
kabinett ist der anwesende
staatsministers leider nicht anwesend
wir reden den osten und erst nicht da
ein falsches signal richtung osten herr
bundeskanzler
mit dem magneten für
zukunftstechnologien sind wir im osten
deutschland kraftzentrum im bereich
wirtschaft geworden im bereich
zukunftstechnologien aber auch im
bereich der wirtschaft denken sie nicht
nur an die erfolgsgeschichte in sachsen
mit dem silicon valley die dresden heute
zum mikroelektronikstandort nummer 1 in
der welt hat werden lassen denken sie an
das tesla werk herr bundeskanzler wurde
gestern waren oder stellen sie sich vor
was wir ein kräftiger schub 17
milliarden euro investitionen an die
landeshauptstadt von sachsen-anhalt nach
magdeburg bringen mit dem standort von
intel das sind gute nachrichten und da
tun wir natürlich gut daran dass wir in
den neuen bundesländern im osten
deutschland auch selbstbewusst sagen in
den letzten jahren gab es die letzten
großen investition nur im osten
deutschland bei 16 jahre regierung unter
cdu csu posten in den vordergrund
gestellt haben eine der ersten banken
kann
und ich würde mich freuen wenn die ampel
regierung diesen klaren kurs fortsetzt
und sprechen wir über den haushalt
kollege fricke von der fdp hat ja auch
ein paar haushalts kennzahlen gesagt
komm ich später dazu aber es gibt auch
dinge die kosten kein geld die kann man
schon nicht nur mit einer starken
opposition umsetzen sondern auch in der
ampel da ist das thema danke kollege und
heute merkt von der fdp wir brauchen
schnellere planungs und
genehmigungsprozesse wenn wir uns die
innerstaatlichen grenze anschauen von
vor 32 jahren dann sind dort in der
regel nicht elektrifizierte bahnstrecken
beispielsweise magdeburg über
haldensleben nach wolfsburg um diese
strecke zu elektrifizieren brauchen wir
alleine für den genehmigungsverfahren
zehn jahre so lange darf das nicht
dauern wenn wir klimawandel ernst meinen
dann muss ein schnelleres planungs und
genehmigungsrecht jetzt umgesetzt werden
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
von dann haben sie es in der mehrheit in
den aufsichtsgremien von nachgeordneten
einrichtungen wie beispielsweise der
bundesagentur für arbeit der
kreditanstalt für wiederaufbau aber auch
dem umweltbundesamt um zukünftige posten
auch mit ost biografien zu besitzen und
da sehe ich eher bundeskanzler vom thema
respekt gegenüber dem osten nicht sowohl
in der br wird jetzt andrea nahles
versorgt als auch in der kfw als auch im
umweltbundesamt obwohl war eine
umweltministerin aus dessau roßlau haben
würzig kein ossi wiederfinden und das
geht nach 32 jahren nicht mehr auf die
haut eines bosses meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren
und das sind zwei punkte die sie ohne
geld machen können und wenn wir uns
ihrer
ampel anschauen nach 107 und tagen und
die auf den prüfstand stellen dann
hatten sie ja gesagt dass sie den osten
zur chefsache machen wollen und deswegen
auch die zentrale koordinierungsfunktion
übernehmen wollen doch koordinierung ist
weit gefehlt schauen wir uns den
haushalt an zu steigen die
personalkosten für den ostbeauftragten
um 1,6 millionen euro obwohl das von uns
damals eingeführte ehrenamts programm
wir machen hieß es in der überschrift
nicht mehr stattfindet wo es der respekt
gegenüber dem osten wir brauchen keine
versorgungsposten für sozialdemokraten
wir brauchen vor ort hilfe damit der
osten unterstützt werden kann da müssen
ansetzen
wir befinden uns inmitten der größten
flüchtlingsbewegung in europa seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg
und gerade in den östlichen
bundesländern
werden diese flüchtlinge aufgenommen sie
kommen in berlin an sie kommen im osten
an sie kommen in dresden an sie kommen
an der grenze
und ja wir
werden auch im osten dieser
verantwortung gerecht
nur erwarte ich dann von einem
bundeskanzler
führung ich erwarte von einem
bundeskanzler antworten auf die fragen
wie eine flüchtlings verteilung
innerhalb deutschlands aber insbesondere
innerhalb der europäischen union
ausgestaltet werden kann da sind sie
sprach es herr bundeskanzler
wir müssen auch erwarten können
dass wir weitere maßnahmen in den neuen
bundesländern brauchen und wir haben gut
bezahlte arbeitsplätze
wir haben zukunftstechnologie wir haben
freie märkte die gefüllt werden können
wir haben auch freier kita-plätze wir
haben die beste kindergärten versorgung
in der ganzen bundesrepublik wenn wir
uns in austin gesamtheit anschauen aber
was wir nicht haben ist ein
förderprogramm und lehrern wohlstand
wohnungs stand aufzubauen
der kleber minister habe kann das
kfw-programm eingestampft was ist das
für ein fatales signal
jetzt bräuchten wir erneuerbare energien
nicht nur auf der einen seite sondern
energetische maßnahmen und den
wohnungsbestand im osten zu sanieren da
sind sie gefordert der bundeskanzler
zum thema staatsminister schneider habe
ich schon was gesagt er ist leider nicht
da darum kann ich die seite mal zur
seite schieben das kann nur dann
nachlesen oder wir haben das im nächsten
mal den bilateralen gespräch sagen
aber das thema ist auch noch was wichtig
ist weil sie hatten gesagt sie wollen
das zur chefsache machen indem sie dir
das amt aufwerten wollen indem sie es
ins bundeskanzleramt holen und der
staatsminister schneider in seiner
ersten rede hier als staatsminister sagt
dass er
diese regierung das ost gesicht geben
möchte und bundeskanzler olaf scholz ich
zitiere wird den osten zur chefsache
erklären aber eins würde ich ihnen auch
sagen lieber ampel ich bitte darum
verständnis dass es mir nach 100 tagen
zunehmend sorge bereitet wenn olaf
scholz etwas zur chefsache erklärt
infektionsschutzgesetz impfpflicht
stärkender bundeswehr und dann noch den
osten dann soll es doch lieber beim
nicht anwesenden staatsminister
schneider bleiben dann hat es zumindest
ein ausländer hand meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren
und wir haben heute in ihren
ausführungen nichts zum thema
kohle gehört drei von vier bundesländern
sind betroffen beim ausstieg aus der
braunkohleverstromung aber was wir lesen
konnten und das ist sehr interessant ich
zitiere mit erlaubnis der präsidentin
aus dem noch nicht geeint papier
maßnahmenpaket zum umgang mit hohen
energiepreisen hat
spd-minister highline formulieren lassen
ich zitiere die bundesregierung muss bei
der fragen der einheimischen
gasförderung auch gesellschaftliche
gesellschaftspolitischen sprengstoff im
blick behalten bereits das aufschieben
der stilllegung von kohlekraftwerken
wird auf widerstand stoßen
widerstand der heil gibt es aus der
arbeitnehmerschaft gegen ihre
vorgezogenen pläne der kohlekraft
stilllegung halten sie sich an den plan
bleiben sie bei 2038 alles andere ist
kokolores
sepp müller war das hier noch mal mit
einer direkten ansprache richtung
regierungsbank
der stand teil der wieder zeit ich habe
das dem kollegen fricke gestern schon
sagen müssen das muss ich auch hier an
dieser stelle
bundestags-vizepräsidentin petra pau
erinnert noch einmal an die redezeit
gerichtet sepp müller aus sachsen anhalt
kommt der übrigens svenja stadler
spricht jetzt für die spd fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wissen sie herr
müller die ampelkoalition redet nicht
sie macht einfach
und alleine die reaktion zeigt ja dass
sie das zu treiben film
seit zwei jahren nun reden wir oder
begleitet uns das thema corona ja schon
in unserem alltag und in der
vergangenheit haben wir oft reagiert und
jetzt handeln wir zukunftsorientiert
haben wir doch zu beginn nicht gewusst
wie wir mit intensiv patienten umgehen
bzw die ärztinnen und ärzte dann sind
wir heute doch in dem bereich ein ganzes
stück weiter und vielleicht erinnern sie
sich am anfang hatten wir gar keinen
impfstoff inzwischen durch nicht genug
impfstoff und jetzt haben wir
ausreichend für alle impfstoff vorhanden
und konnten wir uns am anfang nicht
vorstellen was isolation bedeutet für
menschen und gerade ja auch für ältere
und für kinder und jugendliche dann
wissen wir jetzt doch jetzt und unser
handeln ist sehr viel weitsichtiger in
diesem bereich und in diesen zwei jahren
ist der gesundheitsetat auf 52
milliarden euro angewachsen das ist gut
so und das ist richtig so für die
gesellschaft aber doch auch für die
impfstoff strategie und vor allen dingen
doch auch für die medizinische
infrastruktur
ja
einige und lieber union nicht wieder
besonders ein einige würden jetzt sagen
mensch läuft auch haken dran nächstes
projekt aber das machen wir in der
ampelkoalition nicht so und auch nicht
unser gesundheitsminister lauterbach wir
stellen uns nämlich die frage was ziehen
wir denn aus der pandemie für die
zukunft welche fragen müssen wir uns
stellen damit das gesundheitssystem auch
zukunftsfähig ist und das hat uns eben
auch bei den haushaltsberatungen
begleitet und macht es zukünftig ebenso
und wir brauchen doch ist es auch klar
eine infrastruktur wir brauchen eine
infrastruktur um auf die nächsten
pandemie schnellstmöglich reagieren zu
können sowohl was die forschung betrifft
aber doch eben auch was die produktion
betrifft und in dem bereich haben wir
bereits schon die grundlagen geschaffen
und bedachte
dass der busfahrer glänzer aufhört muss
spätestens bei corona gemerkt haben dass
das eben nicht der fall ist und deswegen
nehmen wir auf der verantwortung an und
sehen es als selbstverständlichkeit
sowohl national als auch international
unseren beitrag zu leisten und eben auch
im bereich der whu unsere beiträge
permanent zu steigern und pop auf höchst
und homeschooling und kinderbetreuung zu
hause das war richtig anstrengend
und wer glaubt dass das einfach mal so
nebenbei gemacht ist einige hier wissen
doch wie schwer das ist und dazu kommt
bei vielen menschen eben doch die sorge
der finanziellen grundlage was passiert
jetzt und deshalb müssen wir uns doch
genau anschauen was jetzt passiert ist
wir sehen die anzahl derjenigen von
kindern und jugendlichen die eine
verhaltensauffälligkeit haben die steigt
wir sehen auch die steigende zahl bei
krankheitstagen und chur anträgen von
erwachsenen und wir müssen uns doch um
die gerade um die langzeiterkrankungen
bykow wird kümmern und genauso auch um
die menschen die von diesen ganzen
corona maßnahmen einfach nur erschöpft
sind pillen alleine reichen nicht und es
reiche auch keine spezialkliniken es
gibt viele klinik verbunden und auch
sektor übergreifende netzwerke und die
gilt es doch jetzt zu stärken und
darüber hinaus bedarf es eines
ganzheitlichen ansatzes eben bestehend
aus mehreren maßnahmen und wissen sie
das wer den koalitionsvertrag der ampel
gelesen hat stellt fest dass wir aus der
pandemie gelernt haben dort sind schon
die ersten schritte hin so einen
zukunftsfähigen gesundheitssystem und
deswegen bin ich dankbar die koalition
vor allem die ampel hat es im blick und
wir geben sicherheit im wandel und das
ist gut so und
das
im einzelnen bedeutet für den
gesundheitsetat das diskutieren wir
morgen vormittag ich freue mich darauf
vielen dank
wenn ihr stadler war das um was man
natürlich noch hinzufügen kann das
phoenix auch diese debatte übertragen
wird wir sind natürlich man hier auch
live dabei wenn unter anderem über den
etat des gesundheitsministeriums
diskutiert wird nächste rednerin aber in
der generalaussprache bist nun chinas
gambier für bündnis 90 die grünen im
deutschen bundestag
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen noch bis sonntag finden die
internationalen wochen gegen rassismus
statt das ist gut so viele menschen
können es sich nicht aussuchen sie
erleben fast täglich rassismus
rassismus fängt nicht erst mit gewalt an
es tief in unserer gesellschaft und auch
in unseren staatlichen institutionen
verwurzelt er zeigt sich da wo menschen
aufgrund ihres äußeren ihres namens
ihrer vermeintlichen kultur abgewertet
ausgegrenzt und benachteiligt werden es
ist an der zeit dass wir rasmus endlich
strukturell bekämpfen und der aktiv
erlernt wird
staatsministerin riemen alaba radovan
zuerst
antirassismus beauftragten zu machen war
ein erster wichtiger schritt der neuen
bundesregierung
[Applaus]
derzeit wir wollen rassismus endlich
ganzheitlich und koordiniert bekämpfen
unter anderem mit einem partizipations
gesetzänderung im agg und natürlich mit
dem demokratie fördergesetz dass
ministerin eine spiegel nun auf den weg
gebracht hat
[Applaus]
nicht nur in diesen tag erleben wir wie
stark unsere zivilgesellschaft ist und
was sie bereit ist zu leisten über 220
230.000 menschen sind bisher aus der
ukraine nach deutschland gefroren jeden
tag sind es mehr menschen ich bin froh
dass ihnen hier unkompliziert sicherheit
und schutz gewährt wird
es ist gut und richtig dass sie
unbürokratisch einreisen können eine
auszeit erlaubnis erhalten zugang zum
arbeitsmarkt in bildungseinrichtungen
für kinder bekommen und zu
integrationskursen erhalten
wir sehen wie viele kapazitäten und
möglichkeiten wir haben wenn wir nur
wollen
und ja es gibt viele bemühungen damit
bund länder und kommunen sich
bestmöglich unterstützen können um
gemeinsam den menschen in und aus der
ukraine zu helfen
doch hier brauchen wir noch viel mehr
koordinierung am besten direkt aus dem
kanzleramt
[Applaus]
insgesamt geht alle menschen haben das
recht auf flucht vor krieg verfolgung
und elend und auf ein leben in
sicherheit ganz ganz gleich welchen pass
sie haben vor welchem krieg und wann sie
fliehen mussten wir zeigen uns mit allen
geflüchteten solidarisch es darf keine
geflüchteten erster und zweiter klasse
[Applaus]
und auch deshalb ist es so wichtig jetzt
eine integrationsoffensive zu starten
alle posten im bereich integration
müssen aufgestockt werden hier muss der
bund seiner verantwortung die er im
rahmen der jetzt die den
haushaltsberatungen hat gerecht werden
dies gilt vor allem auch für den
ergänzungs haushalt lassen sie uns
weiterhin diesen solidarischen weg
gemeinsam bestreiten vielen dank
die beauftragte der bundesregierung für
kultur und medien hat hier schon
gesprochen claudia roth wahrscheinlich
wird es in der nächsten jede auf um
diesen bereich gegen christian
schenderlein ist nämlich die sprecherin
für kultur und medien der unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen bereits
am zweiten kriegstag sangen hunderte
menschen vor dem brandenburger tor die
europahymne am sonntag nahmen am
gleichen ort tausende am sound of peace
konzertteil und auch das
sinfonieorchester von kiew spielte
vergangene woche die ode an die freude
wieder einmal ist es die musik die
kultur die verbindet die aktuelle lage
in europa erfordert es dass wir
gemeinsam dafür sorge tragen dass das so
bleibt daher möchte ich zu beginnen
unseren dank auch an die
kulturstaatsministerin richten sie haben
die hierzu gespräche geführt eine task
force eingerichtet und ein
soforthilfeprogramm aufgeregt aber klar
ist dies entspricht auf unsere
erwartungshaltung an eine
staatsministerin
wir stehen an der seite der
künstlerinnen und künstler sowie
journalistinnen und journalisten in der
ukraine
in russland und in belarus
leider müssen wir in diesen schweren
zeiten auch unserem tagesgeschäft
nachgehen der hier vorgelegte
kulturhaushalt der ampel regierung
strebt an den erfolgskurs der union
zumindest fiskalisch fortzuführen es hat
sich noch nie bezahlt gemacht eine
kultur zu sparen erst recht nicht in
diesen zeiten daher setzen wir die von
uns erreichten zwei milliarden euro
diese setzen die maßstäbe für die ampel
der bund hat sich in den letzten jahren
als verlässlicher partner erwiesen
mit 45 prozent trägt die kommunale ebene
aber nach wie vor den löwenanteil an den
kulturausgaben die korona pandemie hat
in diesem zusammenspiel eine neue
dimension aufgezeigt ohne den bund geht
es nicht dass regierungs und vereine das
rettungsprogramm neustadt kultur war und
bleibt die richtige antwort zum erhalt
unserer vielfältigen kulturlandschaft
im vergleich
europaweit ist das eine einzigartige
kraftanstrengung daher begrüßen wir das
vorhaben der ampel in einen intensiveren
austausch mit den ländern zu treten das
im koalitionsvertrag angekündigte plenum
kultur lässt aber noch auf sich warten
mehrfach haben wir hier eine
konkretisierung eingefordert während die
angestellten künstler durch das
kurzarbeitergeld aufgefangen wurden
mussten die freischaffenden künstler oft
monatelang um ihre existenz bangen dies
zu ändern sollte ein
parteiübergreifendes anliegen in der
wahlperiode sein für uns ist von größter
bedeutung
dass bestehende sich lange bewährte
strukturen nicht in frage gestellt
werden und neue schwerpunkte in
aktuellen herausforderungen gerecht
werden wir haben zum beispiel zweifel ob
ein neues 6,5 millionen euro programm
mit dem titel globaler süden derzeit
priorität haben muss es wird auch
eigentlich in die zuständigkeit des
auswärtigen amtes oder ob das neue 5
millionen euro kultur klimaprogramm noch
in diesem jahr zu einer verbesserten
kulturförderung beiträgt wir sagen ja
nachhaltigkeit und vielfalt aber zu
kunstfreiheit gehört das kultur und sein
darf ohne grün sein zu müssen neue
schwerpunkte im kulturhaushalt dürfen
weder zu belassen
von bestehenden gehen noch zu einer
belastung werden und wir begrüßen die
übernahme der mehrausgaben für die
stiftung preußischer kulturbesitz und
für die deutsche welle aus dem
ursprünglichen regierungsentwurf wir
müssen aber auch sicherstellen dass die
kulturen der fläche vor allem in den
strukturschwächeren regionen gestärkt
wird und dafür haben wir
als union die grundlage gelegt zum
zukunftsprogramm kino oder auch
denkmalschutz sonderprogramm und auch
der buchhandlung preis daran müssen wir
festhalten
die kultur
hat
zwei dramatische jahre hinter sich die
stärkung unserer kultur und kreativ
landschaft und unsere kreativ und
kulturwirtschaft
müssen oberste priorität haben daher
fordere ich die applikation auf dies
nicht aus den augen zu lassen vielen
dank
[Applaus]
das wort die kollegen auch at&s für
jesus für die fraktion bündnis 90/die
geben
frau präsidentin der erde kolleginnen
stellen sie sich vor dass große teile
unseres kulturgutes nicht in unseren
museen legen sondern auf einem anderen
kontinent
stellen sie sich weiter vor sie hätten
noch nie von karl dem großen zum
beispiel gehört weil dieser teil ihrer
geschichte wie ausradiert ist auch werke
von schiller goethe kant liegen nicht in
unseren bibliotheken um sie zu
erforschen müssen sie in ein anderes
land reißen wofür sie ein visum brauchen
was ihnen in der regel nicht gewährt
wird
was würde das mit ihnen machen was würde
das mit uns als gesellschaft machen
was wir hier heute lediglich als
gedankenspiel betreiben es für viele
menschen in afrika asien südamerika
realität große teile ihrer geschichte
liegen in europa in unseren museen
unterschrieben
es ist unsere verantwortung
zurückzugeben was nicht uns gehört
denn nur kultur ist nicht nur nice to
have
kulturspeicher wissen kultur ist wichtig
für die identitätsbildung kultur ist der
diskussions und resonanzraum einer
gesellschaft
und kultur kultur kann noch mehr kultur
kann helfen andere perspektiven
einzunehmen
schritte in den schuhen eines anderen zu
gehen und so ist kultur eine wichtige
chance dafür pluralismus und den
zusammenhalt einer gesellschaft
kultur kann brücken bauen und so kann
deutschland goethe und anton wilhelm
ammersee fassbinder und fatih akin
ostern und besser und bayram und diese
vielfalt ist und stärke
ich danke der
kulturstaatsministerin claudia roth dass
sie diese wichtige diskussion aufgreift
um gelder bereitstellt für die
aufarbeitung des kolonialismus für die
provenienzforschung die die
digitalisierung gramm und bestände aus
unrecht prozent
denn die vergangenheit ist nicht vorbei
die auswirkungen von fest klar von
kolonialismus rassismus sind noch immer
präsent wir können den herpes
gesellschaften heute in zukunft nur auf
augenhöhe begegnen wenn wir dem katana
liz muss ablegen
unserer unsere postkoloniale
erinnerungskultur fans genau damit
schaffen wir eine erinnerungskultur die
einer modernen migrations gesellschaft
gerecht wird und sich nicht von
eurozentrismus leiten lässt der
vorgelegte haushaltsplan sehr wichtiges
signal er macht hoffnung aber er gibt
uns aufgaben mit und die packen wir an
aber das ist wahr das
90 grünen gesprochen und langsam kommen
wir zu den liebsten rednern in dieser
generalaussprache
kerstin radomski ist das sitzt im
haushaltsausschuss und das mitglied der
unionsfraktion die frau präsidentin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der etat
des bundeskanzlers auch einzelplan 04
genannt umfasst viele wichtige bereiche
von der kontrolle der nachrichtendienste
bis zur integration sehr geehrte
kolleginnen gambia und harwich ich
möchte auf die integration
staatsministerin eingehen wenn sie sich
den bereich im bundeskanzleramt genau
angucken können sie feststellen dass die
unterschiede vom ersten
regierungsentwurf zum zweiten
regierungsentwurf den wir jetzt
vorliegen haben im grunde genommen nicht
vorhanden sind obwohl mir fällt auf es
gibt einen kleinen unterschied unsere
kulturstaatsministerin hat bei den
maßnahmen gegen rassismus ganze zehn
millionen euro in den ersten
regierungsentwurf geschrieben jetzt sind
wir bei 8 mio ich möchte mit meiner rede
mich aber auch die kultur konzentrieren
und freue mich dass die
kulturstaatsministerin schon vor mir
einige akzente gesetzt hat
die im entwurf vorgesehenen 2,1
milliarden euro sind ein zeichen dass
der bund die kultur auch finanziell in
angespannten zeiten würde ich das muss
man sagen der entwurf steht damit auch
hier in der tradition der bisherigen
kultur
kulturstaatsministerin monika grütters
in deren amtszeit der etat erstmals die
zwei milliarden euro grenze überstieg
2021 ergänzt um eine milliarde für das
konjunktur und rettungsprogramme
neustart kultur dass viele
kulturschaffende durch die pandemie
gebracht hat für uns hier im bundestag
gilt es ist gut dass wir bei diesem etat
mehr als in anderen bereichen
fraktionsübergreifend an einem strang
ziehen
sinnvoll finde ich deshalb dass sie auch
hier projekte und förderungen der
vorgängerregierung weiterführen und wie
schon geplant finanziell aufwachsen
lassen dazu gehören zb die auch von
ihnen erwähnten stiftung preußischer
kulturbesitz mit einem aufwuchs von 5,7
millionen euro und die deutsche welle
mit 13 5 millionen euro zusätzlicher
unterstützung
die noch von der großen koalition
initiierte stiftung orte der deutschen
demokratiegeschichte wurde erstmals als
institution jetzt im bk im haushalt
aufgenommen bei ihrer gründung war uns
wichtig das bewusstsein insbesondere der
jüngeren generation für den wert der
freiheitlich demokratischen grundordnung
zu schärfen und
trotz aller anerkennenden worte möchte
ich betonen dass wir als opposition
ihrer arbeit wachsam und kritisch
begleiten kunst lebt von freiheit der
gedanken und ferne von ideologie wer in
ihrem koalitionsvertrag aufmerksam liest
kommt unweigerlich zu dem gedanken dass
die dort erwähnte greencard schafft ein
wenig mehr ideologie beladen ist als sie
es zugeben
deshalb lautet mein appell sie lassen
sie sich nicht zu sehr von der
hauptstadt zentrierten debatten
vereinnahmen die vom rest ablenken das
wohl unserer künstlerinnen und künstler
hängt nicht von
aufgeregten kritikern des kreuzes auf
der kuppel des humboldt forum ab sondern
ob die soziale situation von
kulturschaffenden verbessert wird und
die dies gerade auch in der fläche
deutschlands
wenn sie bitte zum schluss
für uns ist es wichtig dass sie sich
konkret bemühen deshalb treten sie in
den kontakt mit den kulturschaffenden
auch in ihrem größten projekt im
einzelplan dem humboldtforum aus um die
inneren sie bitte zum schluss es steht
hier direkt in berlin es eröffnet es ist
eröffnet es ist ein besuch wert ich
freue mich auf die verhandlungen und
danke für die aufmerksamkeit und ich
vergessen machen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich melde
mich wieder zurück zu stärken
und als nächster redner erhält das wort
der fraktionslose matthias helferich
vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren ich ich ich ich
kein wort dominierte die darbietung von
emilia fester aus der letzten woche
stärker kein wort spiegelt den geist
ihres haushaltsentwurfs besser wieder
egozentrik selbstbedienungsmentalität
patronage 165 millionen euro für ihr
projekt demokratie leben der
vermeintliche kampf gegen rechts ist nur
ein patronage system für all jene die
nach ihrem gescheiterten studium keinen
platz in diesem parlament erhielten wie
kevin kühnert und daher als berufs
antifaschisten versorgt werden müssen
sie haben ihr ag pop privatisiert und
finanzieren ihr vorfeld netz der
gehirnwäsche und propaganda auf
steuerzahlerkosten 8 millionen euro für
ein beratungszentrum samt zentrale
hotline zur erstellung eines rassismus
barometers
präventionsprogramme gegen den
islamistischen extremismus
lassen sie hingegen austrocknen statt
fünf millionen euro und 22 jetzt nur
noch drei millionen euro eigentlich
müssten ihnen die gez zwangs milliarden
zur herrschaft sicherung gleichen möchte
man meinen doch sie lassen sich auch
eine regierungsnahe hof schon etwas
kosten oder besser den steuerzahler 3
millionen euro stellen sie zum schutz
und zur strukturellen förderung
journalistischer arbeit zur verfügung
eine regierungskritische journalismus
wäre ja auch gefährlich er könnte ja
über weitere verfehlungen der ampel
minister berichten wie jungs über
familienministerin spiegel die nicht nur
in der flutkatastrophe versagte und sich
lieber um ihr image sorgte aber auch
beim heutigen haushaltsentwurfs auch
beim heutigen haushaltsentwurfs
versäumen sie es die opfer von fluten zu
entschädigen hunderte plünderer aus 24
nationen nutzten das leid der flutopfer
aus und bereicherten sich an ihrem hab
und gut entschädigung für die deutschen
opfer natürlich fehlanzeige ihr
haushaltsentwurf ist das produkt einer
abgehobenen kaste die nur noch sich
selbst im blick hat sie betreiben wie es
finanzminister lindner gestern sagte
stabilitätspolitik aber es ist
stabilitätspolitik für die eigene macht
und da verwundert es nicht dass die des
erasmus stiftung nicht mit mitteln
bedacht wird es ist der futterneid der
ihg aderlass in diesem hause der das
erstarken oppositioneller kräfte
fürchtet dieser haushalt steht für die
entsolidarisierung mit dem eigenen volk
und für die versorgung des
linksliberalen eigenen milieus vielen
dank
matthias helferich war das und die
bundestagspräsidentin aydan özoguz hat
hier ja eben noch einmal das plenum
begrüßt sie war nämlich corona positiv
und da musste sie eine zwangspause ein
halber hat die letzte rednerin in dieser
debatte ist paula piotta von bündnis 90
die grünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen helferich ist
sehr gut dass gleich nach ihnen eine von
diesen grünen frauen sprechen kann man
muss nicht alles teilen was sie sagen
aber solidarität mit emilia fester mit
einem spiegel und auch mit ricaner
langen
und jetzt zurück zum thema ich freue
mich wahnsinnig dass der beauftragte für
die neuen länder der beauftragte für
ostdeutschland jetzt endlich wieder teil
dieser debatte ist und lieber carsten
schneider
sie haben auch in den letzten wochen
schon sehr viel gesprochen über die
wirtschaftsförderung die wir brauchen im
osten über gute arbeitnehmer/innen
rechte im osten die wir brauchen da
wären sie uns auch immer an ihrer seite
wissen ich glaube aber fahne in diesen
zeiten mit der kante hat am anfang
dieser debatte darüber gesprochen wenn
wir den großen rückhalt in der
bevölkerung brauchen der ja zweifelsohne
da ist dann müssen sie aber auch darüber
sprechen dass obwohl jetzt auch im osten
gerade viele gewissheiten im banken sind
und die macht des faktischen auch bei
uns im osten dazu führt dass viele neu
darüber nachdenken dass wir ihn für uns
verhältnis zu russland haben das immer
noch extreme unterschiede auch in der
einstellung zur nato auch in diesen
wochen auf extreme unterschiede in der
einstellung dazu dass die maßnahmen der
bundesregierung jetzt berechtigt sind
zwischen ost und west existieren und
liebe linda teuteberg wenn sie jetzt
noch da wäre würde ich ihr sagen ja man
kann nicht alles nach ost und west mal
eingruppieren aber man kann auch nicht
weg reden dass es bestimmte unterschiede
zb auch in der korona krise einfach
immer noch gibt
dass der oft beauftragte jetzt wieder im
bundeskanzleramt angesiedelt ist das ist
es dafür am viele leute in diesem haus
gekämpft aber auch außerhalb dieses
hauses und deswegen muss man hier auch
noch mal danke sagen an die vielen in
der zivilgesellschaft in den medien die
vor allen dingen 2015 angefangen haben
als dritte generation ostdeutschland
auch als vierte generation oss scheint
wenn ich das ja mal so nennen darf leute
die nach 76 geboren sind und die endlich
wieder angefangen haben lauter und
vernehmbarer und gründlicher darüber zu
diskutieren wo die probleme aus
deutschland sind und wie wir auch mit
der analyse dieser probleme zu einer
lösung kommen damit wir am ende auch in
diesen schweren zeiten die jetzt kommen
werden eine breite grundlage der
gesellschaftlichen solidarität und
akzeptanz der maßnahmen für die
bundesregierung auch in diesen schweren
zeiten in ost und in west haben kinder
vielen dank für politik
weitere wortmeldungen zu diesem
einzelplan liegen nicht vor